aujourd'hui je ne veux rien expliqué je
veux juste dire merci merci à l'ensemble
du personnel soignant des hôpitaux qui
depuis plusieurs semaines lutte contre
le coronavirus et sauve des vies
les médecins les infirmiers les aides
soignants masculin et féminin le
personnel administratif les pompiers les
ambulanciers les pharmaciens également
le personnel des établissements
d'accueil
les forces de l'ordre mais comme
aujourd'hui c'est la journée du travail
invisible est que nous sommes tous
confinés
je voulais aussi salué le travail de
celles et ceux que nous voyons plus ou
auxquelles nous ne pensons pas les
boulangers les minotiers qui continuent
à moudre du blé pour que nous ayons de
la farine et du pain
les éleveurs qui continue à s'occuper de
leurs animaux à traire leurs vaches
leurs brebis et leurs chèvres qui pour
certains continuent à faire du fromage
le personnel des laiteries qui
continuent à ramasser le lait à le
transformer merci à nos bouchers nos
charcutier nos fromages et nos
passionnés
merci à nos producteurs de céréales de
fruits et de légumes qui travaillent
dans leurs champs qui taille qui récolte
qui plantait qui sème pour que d'ici
quelques semaines quelques mois nous
ayons dans nos assiettes et dans nos
verres de bons produits
merci à tous ceux qui les conditionnent
et les achemine vers nos magasins à ceux
qui le mettent en place les caissiers
les caissières le personnel d'entretien
de maintenance de traitement des déchets
merci à tous ceux qui nous permette
d'avoir de l'électricité du gaz
derrière chaque produit que nous
consommons chaque service qu'une
utilisons il y à une filière avec des
femmes et des hommes qui réalisent des
tâches que nous ne connaissons pas merci
aux journalistes qui continuent à nous
informer aux enseignants qui continue à
travailler à distance aux météorologues
qui regardent le ciel au volcanologues
qui surveille les vols plan aux
biologistes qui ont l'oeil rivé sur le
coronavirus aux chercheurs qui continue
à chercher car plus que jamais on ne
sait pas ce que nous réserve l'avenir
merci à tous ceux qui font que même en
plein confinement la vie continue
presque comme avant
et pardon à tous ceux que je n'ai pas
cité aller à demain et surtout n'oubliez
pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant bien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle
chaque jour alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain